i remember talking guys going back to
ubereats i remember there's this thai
place that i ordered
i ordered from whenever i'm like i'm
missing home or whatever yeah but
like it's the one that we get i have no
idea it's the really fun oh i like
pretty [ __ ] yeah it's really crazy
like four times a week
yeah but like i get the craving every
now and again because i'm very picky
when it comes to thai food
and like my problem with this place is
that they they never [ __ ] make it
spicy enough
that is
like every time i'm sure they [ __ ]
nobody might know me by name now because
every time i'm just like
spicy please spicy like the comments
yeah i put it in the comments i'm like
spicy fleas and it's just
it's just never spicy enough like i open
it and i could tell that they put like a
few few
chili flakes on there and it just opens
it doesn't even smell like no no i i you
know
you can take it back you can you can
tell when someone didn't try with the
spice right it's it's like
there's high chilies and then there's
like chili flakes
so like last week there's one time i'm
just like let me try something different
so i
i asked for it spicy again right but i
don't i don't type it in japanese
i type it in thai oh yeah
so it's iphone thai okay and i remember
opening
i remember getting the same takeaway box
opening up this package and this thing
looked like it had been
cooked in like the flames of hell
[ __ ]
lucifer grilled this himself i open it
and like the chili to rice
like ratio was just like it was more
chili than rice
would you like rice on your chili can
you copy paste what you sent to him i
wanna i wanna see this i wanna try this
yeah sure i i've never been more happy
in my life was it good
it was good okay okay i was like i
ordered the pack
pal and like pad grappau is like
normally really really spicy yeah and
you know it's spicy
when like you have to like you you you
have trouble finding the meat
through the chili right because it's
it's
like you got you got you got the normal
you've got the normal meats and then
you've got like the red
and green chili flakes or not just just
like raw chillies yeah i'm just like
you're my brother now now now now i know
you're a brother
just um the indian place near here
we do like indian food you know we i
think we'd always ask for it really
spicy
like very spicy and it was quite spicy
but it wasn't that bad right
right and i think uh i mean to you guys
level yeah because i mean i
you know even though i i'm extremely
white i love spice that pretty much
cripples me yeah um
and uh yeah just to a standard person
like myself that shit's spicy enough
yeah but to these like [ __ ] spawns of
satan
because in japan when you tell them to
make it like 10 or max they just
they don't do it yeah and the first time
we went there first few times he
the person who was cooking it's always
the same guy he didn't actually make it
that spicy like it was just kind of like
it was definitely japan standing yeah
like it was very it was like on the high
end for japan standard yeah i'd say yeah
yeah and then one time for some reason i
don't know why we went well he decided
this time he was like fine
i'm not playing he's like fine i'm not
playing anymore
and holy [ __ ] this was hard
yeah i was like i got like halfway
through this and i was like i'm actually
in like
severe pain yeah like this is actually
brutal i like god
couldn't finish it wow yeah because it
was i
yeah i think it was the one week where
you had to go home early yeah so we were
in this indian place
yeah he he was not playing around and i
think i think i could see him like in
the corner of my eyes
like he was like watching us because
we've been there so many times we order
the same
the same meal every time we order like
the most spicy option
and it's just like yeah we it's spicy
but it's not like it's it's
like it's it's it's like it's a nice
tingle on your tongue what if he was
like all right the [ __ ] boy is gone
i'm gonna give you guys the real [ __ ]
now but it is it was
by far the spiciest meal i've had in
japan
i could not finish it because it got to
the point where it was just
yeah that's got numb about it like the
last time it was just like i was
enjoyable about that though i don't care
i don't know what it is because like the
flavors get like enhanced by like being
just be
no i get that to a certain extent but
the level you guys have it it's just
like i don't even know what flavor is
anymore
i mean i feel like it depends on the
dish right because i mean you can go to
like coco ichiman
and um so to explain have we have we
talked about that before glacier is like
a japanese curry
they have it in america oh yeah they do
yeah yeah and so you can go to this
curry chain in japan and they have like
a spice scale
from one to ten and like ten is the most
spiciest and i've had the ten before and
so is connor
and for me it was it was actually like
really spicy
but it just it felt like it just felt
like you're adding spice for the sake of
adding spice right
right there are some dishes that i feel
um are designed to be spicy it's not
like flavor enhanced spice right yeah
yeah yeah it's just spice for the sake
of spicy like to me
like a mild curry a mild japanese curry
at least is
as good if not better than some of the
spicier versions but
there are some like thai dishes and
indian dishes and southeast asian dishes
where i feel
if you don't have enough spice to it
there's missing there's missing a
certain kick a certain yeah
it brings out a lot of flavors yeah and
also just a lot of endorphins from the
pain no i get nothing
i'm just like i'm constantly changing i
get i get the i get the fact of like you
know the spice enhances the flavor and
stuff like that because you know i've
had my fashion like southeast asian food
and stuff like that which is quite spicy
and i'm just like oh
this is hard to eat but god damn like
this probably tastes way better than
without the spice
and then there's your guys see the
reason why i got into spicy food
because again i have to bear in mind my
parents fall like paprika was spicy so
yeah when i was growing up i didn't
really eat spicy food but i just when i
started doing youtube i started doing
the like [ __ ] stupid peppa challenge
yeah yeah and i've done it so many times
where i was like i could handle the
carolina reaper like
semi-comfortably right and i was like
[ __ ] spicy food isn't spicy anymore
because i've just been eating these
peppers raw [ __ ] youtube challenges
and twitch live streams
so i got to the point where i was like
oh god this is like really good now like
i really like it yeah like habaneros on
stuff is like perfect
no see because like i love that when
we're talking about like kokoichi levels
of smoothies right because that's the
easiest gauge
when you're in japan right it's like
what level of kokokuiji can you do
you immediately know like i used i can
now do level three
right but before like couple of years
ago i couldn't even do level one
that was back when joe was wearing a
diaper that's when i was back when i was
wearing a diaper that's when i was a
true [ __ ]
like you need something you need at
least like a two yeah
right but i mean you guys can say that
because you're useless because you've
been eating it you know
yeah but like i mean i mean i feel like
even some foods where there's an option
to pick a spicy
version i don't always pick the spicy
version it very much depends on the dish
and whether it
complements it or not right right i mean
like you know now i could do a level
three and now i understand like oh you
know this is actually
so much better with spice yeah to a
certain degree but like
i had to kind of slowly trick my brain
into thinking
that right because if you had given me a
level three spicy kokuichi like two
years ago
yeah i would have been like what is this
[ __ ] like this isn't enjoyable at all
like
i seek enjoyment out of my meal and this
is not enjoyable i mean i'm in severe
pain
but now i've like slowly started to
appreciate the pain
yeah right joey says getting a level
three yeah
i say that getting a level three yeah
i'm not
getting those endorphins now that's like
honestly like to me like
that's [ __ ] painful but like it's
good painful
right and like now i finally start to
understand i'm like oh okay
these like other friends i knew who
could eat like level seven and eights
who i just thought were like
absolutely [ __ ] maniacs like the noob
anime
character yeah yeah it's so long yeah
it's like i can't it's like i kind of
get it now
after after my training arc i'm slowly
starting to get it